President Trump praised his
administration's response to the crisis
in Puerto Rico and says the governor has
complimented his work the Governor of
Puerto Rico is so thankful for the great
job that we're doing it's the most
difficult job because it's on the island
it's on an island in the middle of the
ocean telling the ocean you can't just
drive your trucks there from other
states and the governor said we are
doing a great job in fact he thanked me
specifically for FEMA and all of the
first responders in Puerto Rico Puerto
Rico governor Ricardo Rocio is with us
from San Juan governor good morning
it's been one week since the hurricane
hit in your islands still ninety-seven
percent without power 50 percent without
water are you in the midst of a
humanitarian disaster it could go that
way but we're making every effort to
prevent that and let me just say we're
we're very pleased with the
communication with the president with
the administration and with FEMA we've
been working as one team this has been
quite a challenge it's a it's a disaster
of unprecedented nature you need to
consider that it's been to category 4 or
5 hurricanes passing through the island
in the span of two weeks and then we're
at an island and resources are harder to
come by so our petition is keep the help
coming we recognize that everything is
being done and we're here to execute so
that we can make sure that people get
food water that we can start approaching
normalcy Qin do you think the power will
be back completely it's hard to say but
but I'll just give you a sense you know
after ARMA none of the towers
transmission towers was broken and it
took us about a we can have to start
getting up to 95 97 percent power now
just playing over I saw several dozen
powers completely destroyed governor the
pictures and the stories we're hearing
from the island are really heartbreaking
what specifically and so many people
want to help what specifically do you
need and what do you want people to do
well
we need resources such as generators we
need a human resource and the security
front brigades we need truck drivers
believe it or not and and equipment so
that we can transport fuel we have fuel
in Porto Rico but transportation has
been the limiting step so those are the
immediate needs that we're that we're
gonna have but if you want to give food
supplies and all of those components or
even donations you can call our hotline
it's two zero two eight hundred three
one three three they will attend to you
governor we have also heard an urgent
plea from help for elected officials our
own David beg no spoke with the mayor of
San Juan yesterday about her
frustrations with FEMA and the federal
government here's what she said look
I'll say it friendly and you can believe
it you know we need to get together yeah
and held needs to get into people's
hands no not tomorrow not later no you
heard what she said she said now people
are dying right well we're working on
every front it is clear that we're
getting resources here in Puerto Rico
the level of the devastation as I'm sure
she understands is unprecedented so
we're getting food as soon as I finish
this interview I'm going to one of the
isolated areas in Puerto Rico to take
food about 40 of our teams are all
around the island making sure that we
get water we get food we get fuel so the
actions are being taken we need to we
need more help of course we need more
help but I am convinced that seeing the
response from the federal government
seeing the response from the
administration and the reply from
Congress you know I've seen a Senator
Schumer senator Rubio on a bipartisan
effort as well as others commit their
support to Puerto Rico so that we can
have immediate aid right now and then we
can have really a mid to long term aid
so that we don't have so that we don't
collapse into a humanitarian crisis in
the United
governor versão thank you so much thank
you god bless